all right well now to the Grammys on CBS
and expect plenty our girl power to take
the stage Sunday night and we are gonna
be there yes we will we cannot wait but
for hostess with the mostest Alicia Keys
she actually got the party started last
night with former Grammy host James
Corden
[Music]
the shallow duet that sort of has kicked
this off did you rehearse what was the
rehearsal process we definitely want her
to trust me cuz first I was like oh boy
imma have to hold back it was in fact he
was better than me I was like wait a
minute can i rehearse one more time he's
better than me
Alisha helped roll out the red carpet
this morning and I found out as of right
now nominee is Beyonce and jay-z are not
attending as for this lady there is a
story out there about Ariana that she
was asked to perform and it wasn't the
song that she wanted to do so she backed
out what is the truth there seven rings
is a new song we discourage artists from
doing new songs let's hope that we see
you next year this afternoon ari tweeted
her response saying in part I offered
three songs I can pull together a
performance overnight and you know that
can it was when my creativity and
self-expression was stifled by you that
I decided not to attend okay check out
the seating arrangements for the Grammys
front and center Lady Gaga directly
behind her Jennifer Lopez and behind JLo
its cardi B and it's gonna be a big
night for her she's nominated for five
Grammys well that sounds even better
because I thought it was boy today the
26 year old appears on the cover of
Harper's Bazaar we also got this
behind-the-scenes look at her brand new
Pepsi commercial that our air during
Sunday's awards just saying okay no no
no okay oh yeah baby yeah my age is now